[Música]
me gustaría saber cuántos de ustedes
saben lo que significa please ok joda o
mortal yo supongo que la gran mayoría lo
sabe pero muy diferente sería si yo les
pregunto qué significa es querer a pr2 o
neri
probablemente los que sí conozcan estos
últimos términos tengan menos de 20 a
los 25 años
me gustaría contarles una pequeña
anécdota sobre esto
hace pocas semanas volvía de casa con el
auto con mis padres y estaba contándoles
cómo había sido mi día hasta que solté
una frase que luego desencadenó muchas
cosas
nada más si yo te hablo
y generó un momento de preguntas de qué
es esto del serio estás hablando así
entonces yo le expliqué que éste armó
era estar en fiesta de rehenes a
pero el día siguiente entra mi mamá en
la cocina y dice hoy estoy enojadísimo
no quiero que ninguno de ustedes me
moleste porque yo estoy modo
yo me reí me forzó explicándole algo
pero ella le dio un significado
totalmente diferente
pero saben lo importante lo importante
es que yo entendí lo que ella quería
decir porque ahora a partir de una
situación cotidiana que podría haber
pasó desapercibida estábamos creando un
punto de encuentro estamos compartiendo
el mismo código
es precisamente sobre eso que vengo a
hablarles hoy sobre como la era de la
comunicación de la información y de la
tecnología influye tanto en la forma de
vida de los adolescentes en nuestra aula
en nuestro comportamiento en nuestra
forma de ser
yo sé que cada una de sus generaciones
tuvo en la adolescencia mujer especial
su forma de hablar su código propio
particular
pero nosotros los empeñas nos marca una
gran diferencia y es el avance el
descubrimiento y los cambios de la
tecnología y el mundo digital en el que
nacimos
pero la realidad es que es precisamente
esto lo que también suele generar un
estereotipo sobre nosotros de que somos
una generación de jóvenes que vaga que
no sabe conectarse que no vale la pena
que jamás va a comprender el verdadero
poder de la palabra pero en realidad yo
creo que simplemente tenemos otras
capacidades quizás hasta se nos
dificulta comunicarnos con alguien que
no conoce o que no comparte el mismo
código el mismo medio o el mismo formato
que nosotros
pero yo vengo a contarles que para mí lo
esencial es la aceptación es el hecho de
que los adultos comprenden que nosotros
no elegimos ser los precursores de este
cambio no elige no elegimos ser los
centenas nosotros nacimos nacimos junto
con la tecnología y estamos avanzando y
transformando nos a la par de ella de
sus cambios y a nosotros nos es
prácticamente imposible prescindir de
ellas pero la realidad es que se está
generando un quiebre y no nos queda más
que buscar una solución a esta brecha
comunicacional que se está formando
entre nuestras generaciones
es por eso que cuando decidí venir acá
hablar con ustedes
pensé en quizás definir ejemplificar o
quizás en pensar si realmente todas esas
palabras que los jóvenes creamos con su
mismo compartimos y realizamos en las
redes y llevamos de una forma cotidiana
natural a nuestra realidad
realmente significaban algo o si
simplemente lo leímos lo compartimos y
lo usamos sin ningún sentido
luego de enumerar las definirlas y
ejemplificar las me di cuenta que la
gran mayoría de esas palabras solía
repetir patrones
algunas por ejemplo son palabras que
trajimos de otro idioma pero que no nos
quedamos con su traducción literal sino
que le dimos un ejemplo más simbólico un
poco distinto por ejemplo pasa con beef
si no solo lo traducimos significa carne
pero nosotros decimos sí vamos a tirarle
beef cuando vamos a pelear porque no se
otro tipo de palabras son esas que
nosotros abríamos o relacionamos solo
porque se nos hace más fácil de
utilizarlas le decimos a tr para
referirnos a todo ritmo o decimos nieve
en la alusión a nuestros compañeros
pero hay otras palabras hay otras
palabras que realmente por sí mismas por
la palabra en sí no significan nada si
yo les digo 2d a red quiere yo sé que no
se las puedo definir pero por alguna
razón nosotros los jóvenes sabemos la
situación perfecta para utilizarlas los
usamos como enfatiza dores de nuestras
ideas como simbolismos como palabras que
creemos propias
también estuve pensando que quizás luego
de ver todo este proceso podríamos
comparar a las redes sociales a internet
sobre todo con una biblioteca en ambas
podemos encontrar grandes cantidades de
información en muchos formatos muchas
formas con muchos contenidos diferentes
claramente el internet aún está en juego
para poder calificar un poco la calidad
y veracidad
de su contenido pero la realidad es que
los jóvenes acudimos a ella
constantemente
en este ejemplo podríamos decir que cada
plataforma o k red social es un libro
distinto y en esos libros más
específicamente en las redes sociales
los jóvenes somos prosumidores
el prosumidor significa que ya no solo
ya no sólo consumimos el contenido sino
que también lo producimos si continuamos
con el ejemplo significaría que nosotros
ya no sólo leemos los libros las
revistas la televisión lo consumimos
sólo el material sino que también
escribimos esos libros nos encontramos
en las redes en la pantalla
constantemente produciendo contenido
compartiendo finalizando encontrando
nuevos temas de los que hablar
pero es importante aclarar que el hecho
de que tengamos tanto acceso e
influencia a la red a las personas a
todo el mundo en cuestión de segundos
tiene su lado negativo el internet tiene
sus desventajas y es muy importante que
seamos cuidadosos que aprendamos a
utilizarlo de una manera más responsable
y observar mejor cuáles son las
verdaderas ventajas que nos otorga creo
que un buen paso para realizarlo sería
visibilizando estos pequeños cambios
estos procesos que nos comienzan a
demostrar que el internet que el mundo
tecnológico va mucho más allá de la
pantalla afecta a nuestros
comportamientos nuestra forma de
comunicarnos con la otra generación
afecta nuestras actitudes nuestro
lenguaje y todo lo que somos como
personas
es por eso que me gustaría invitarlos a
todos grandes y chicos aquí seamos
curiosos a que busquemos estas
situaciones que podamos utilizar a modo
de puentes para conectarnos con la otra
generación yo encontré mi punto de
encuentro quizás mi excusa a través de
estas palabras porque creo que son un
buen intermedio entre el mundo digital
los cambios que generó en mí y el mundo
real donde está esa generación que aún
no es dueña de la tecnología ustedes
alguna vez se preguntaron cómo hacen
para conectarse con el otro cómo se
vinculan con sus padres con sus hijos o
con cualquier persona que realmente les
importe que les importe en serio
yo sé que conectarse que vincularse no
es sencillo más de una vez vamos a
fallar pero creo que lo importante está
en que seamos insistentes en que no
demos esta pelea por perdida que no
dejemos que nuestra sociedad se agriete
en los pre tecnológicos y los híper
cibernéticos sino que encontremos un
punto que nos conecte que hagamos de la
era de la conexión eso y no la era de la
desconexión
y sin duda yo creo que si logramos crear
estos puentes hacer de la vida del día a
día cotidiano un puente que nos
comunique con el otro la brecha
comunicacional que hoy nos separa será
menor y podremos crear con nuestros
padres por ejemplo un vínculo más fuerte
un vínculo mucho más profundo que nos
permite conocernos
es por eso que me gustaría invitarlos a
que no pierdan la oportunidad la
oportunidad de conocer porque no sabemos
que personas tan maravillosas pueden
estar nos esperando al otro extremo del
puente muchas gracias
[Aplausos]